só alguém falar andar que sejam
emendados mais um eu esgotei que o canal
promete trazer um vídeo de graça ao caps
alstom base começaria não fez nenhum
santinho que o canal e claramente o ct
não é que eu fui desafiado e trazer o
melhor material escolar para vocês que
eu achei a hipótese não gostar incluindo
carta sports night lápis de cor e
mochilas como fiquei muito radical mas é
um prestígio pessoal no facebook onde
estava o material caiu também de fazer
um vídeo que eu não posso fazer muito
aqui no canal mas acho que vocês vão
gostar é deste tipos de alunos na escola
e levaram só deixei muito claro que meu
espírito se quiser ver mais vídeos deste
ano e já está no top eu vi o vídeo que
mostraria que manterá ok ok vamos lá
vamos começar a aula a professora é
descansar a água não tem disco rígido de
pcs
por que por que eu fiz dizer adoro o
presente vai consolá-lo lenta que o
previsto nenhum caderno que não têm o
costume o caneco onde podiam postar uma
caneta também pode emprestar um lápis
[Aplausos]
desmatadores
a taxa de 50 euros
andré não foi decidido se o quadro velho
abn news a menina dessa mesma coisa
olha vou te dar um show de maceió muito
é notar os alunos já tinha em rota dos
testes na semana passada mesmo é 1 82%
muito é lixo é a dor a história milhares
estão quase normais no organismo do
menino andré estendidas por cento andré
almeida andré mas isso não vai à mina
crowe né
estou nem aí 99,9 vitó que tem o pico
nota que investiu aplicou nós no texto
se explora a mão em dinheiro vai do
dólar parece sentir a respiração em 2010
mas pode ser que já é matéria do ano
passado não é dois mais trash igual é
cedo e só saiu quando eu mandar um toque
não significa nada na hora e por pouco o
fogo
joão rafael rafael ex professora eu já
não vêm cá 286 dias não vai às aulas o
que realmente estou falando muito vagas
bombinha meninos mais um dia de aulas
não é defeso de pc e ninguém pode fazer
não fez o professor o edifício de pé em
cima do meu cão correu no campo onde o
último empecilho nenhum andré você
desejar outras desculpas aos seus
companheiros tempo não é que você estava
inteira
[Música]
arrume no gre nal agora temos uma
pergunta difícil
os alunos não é qual é a mp é direito
vem você tem que aprender a estudar bota
respondeu nem eusébio tal complementar n
o big bang é uma situação interna que
nasceu no rosto isso do mundo inteiro né
e depois conheceu o constante estrelas
estão menos 12 902 funções de início de
um dvd é óbvio não é a que se sucedeu a
teoria do big bang
bem vamos continuar a lâmina
é a professora não só da professora eu
posso ir à casa de banho tudo fui
aumentos mas quer votar no pt foi peixe
na hora da entrada eo gosto mais e dá
aula
eu só a questão de outra vez agora vão
estar os materiais todos se quiser viver
os grupos destruírem por foi muito
engraçado fazer cometem mas também vamos
lá então estar aqui uma certa eu tenho
pra vocês possivelmente isso fui o que
eu escolheria se tivesse uma escola
ainda e o que eu acho que vocês gostam
então comenta mas se vocês notarem
alguma coisas estarem comendo só quando
você estava em tudo o que vai na noite a
maioria das mochilas que tem lá vem com
acessórios também com coisas é estranho
e olha eles querem que o novo estilo
também eu acho que isso é mais típico de
cada se vocês quiserem para um
computador ou gostava de te querendo eu
acho que é bem segura mesmo então eu
acabei por escolher essa mochila uma
coisa que o amor que nutrem são gostosos
tem este morreu ele respondeu aqui e eu
acho que o outro mas eu adoro isso
porque quando você sabe assim
ae é tendo dentro de uma coisa incrível
só que vocês podem tirar o zip é todos
os títulos o pó sai tudo fica
completamente foi tudo claro foco não
poderia faltar para o nosso em 2009
diminuiu de nós precisamos que a derme
muitos cadernos vocês sabem há muitas
disciplinas porque eu tenho uma alegria
muito grande quer mantém com riscas
enquadrados em com negócios em angola
tem tudo é só escolher alguma coisa
também não pode faltar pessoal e
material escolar para as vossas
disciplinas artísticas tipo mmt play
lápis de cor preta também é que um flyer
o caso agora que a história de sua
pessoa responsável pelas vozes noite
vocês vão reparar que eles não vendem
são material escolar não caí helvético
brinquedos ver nem acessórios nem coisas
lucas então passei lá que valeu a pena
mesmo o hoodie escola muito anel tem que
misturar primeiro calma
assim tá bom eu tinha um carinho o que é
absolutamente entusiasmado não posso
brincar com estas coisas não vi que um
dia tudo é mais uma criança pra você ao
existe que vocês também podem comprar lá
massa provar que eu não sei onde isto é
cobrir os 500 ao vivo é sempre se
inscrever não é ele tem aqui um lápis
bastante de santo tem uma regra é ajudar
minhas coisas podem surgir em matemática
a
eu pensei tudo passou os testes provas
de pcs evenson matemática pam am e oeste
lápis e borracha tinha eu já vos mostrar
as minhas coisas favoritas mais pro fim
do vídeo até plantas stop kimi
mercadorias para marcar os nossos livros
manuais acho que é importante uma coisa
que dá sempre jeito com costa a costa
as vossas dos nossos limites também
quiserem marcador é muito importante
também para vocês não darem alguns
apontamentos mais importante o lápis
quem tem 500 que tem que ter uns 30 e
lápis obrigatoriamente eu sei que vocês
precisam disse também que umas cartas do
forte né anthony sol de fortunato o ato
em la como ninguém só vocês também podem
comprar a caderneta de fortunato
procurarem os autocolantes o ao cair mas
eu não tenho certeza se o ataque mas
deve ter é muito provável não sei se são
cartões sons ricas
só comprei também uma leve a pensar em
você só vocês quiserem ler o voto manual
nosso livro a noite
vocês podem usar uma blusa e disse
estranhar o meio ambiente sem usar esse
mapa das casas em que está a emergir a
voz também tanto usa no papel é muito
eficaz por aí é só história olímpica
para ler também um bosta é à toa que
tinha lá eu não sei que gostaria mas aos
poucos para o que a marvel em cima dos
vendedores muito lotou e as coisas
favoritas que eu escolhi essa mochila
tem aqui dentro
pensavam que esta caneca também pode ser
mas não é só um estilo pato não é medo
ela mostrou é simples a provar pra todo
lado
estamos usando o que tem aqui uns
queremos dentro
vejam só temos aqui um caderno para
acontecimentos e um caderno com a iese
um caderno mas é muito louco por ter
aqui que põe os estudantes de matemática
e coisas assim mas só como explica uma
caneca para vocês pra vocês tomaram o
pequeno-almoço olha aí as coisas não
tenho aqui mãe para conseguir reunir em
todos os nossos trabalhos e todas as
vossas folhas de cálculo e folhas
portuguesa ea tetra os cliques e também
algumas campinas podem levar tudo aqui
dentro eu estava aqui é mais focada nos
capazes nem está aqui pra quem gosta do
holz
as meninas têm aqui também esta opção eu
acho que eu usei esta é muito mais longo
caso eu só comentei que as escolhiam é
um ou dois comenta ele também que nunca
da roça para as meninas
escolhi que também ocidental ou para as
meninas ou até mesmo pra mim porque eu
comigo eu usaria isso nem fácil fácil e
rosa prudente e não pessoal eu acho que
tudo aqui não ainda tenho esse perfil
que eu não estarei aqui é um é uma firma
para lápis em forma de café
olha aí mas fica aqui dentro de tudo o
que o nosso estudo e um café
agora sem solo eu acho que tá tudo isso
é o material escolar que os